well, we are offering some courses
at the immigrant house and also in
the association with the indec really and
we are offering it in the community in
rafael rivera walk and heal and they are
english castells where students
can take their courses for free and
also  you can start the process so
you want to get your video your
high school equivalency right there in
the center so you don't have to come
so you can go to the center and
we'll be there we are free there is
no cost to anyone and
anyone above  A 16-year-old who is
interested in learning English or improving
her English, she can go to these courses, the
courses start right now and I'm going
to give you a number: 65 14 487, you can
call or you can go
for a walk and dinner and you
can also get a referral right there  the data but
the courses can start at any
time and are based on the intensity
of the students since they do not start and
finish they always continue as long as  When
the place for the student arrives, that's how it is
last week we announced that the
school of his relief in conjunction with
Casa del Immigrante and Green Bay Nevada,
an organization that helps
dreamers and dreamers and we are going to create
a collaboration to offer
free classes  of English as a second language,
these courses are free, it will not
cost the community anything at all
and this is to help people who
do not know how to speak English learn the
basics
to be able to improve themselves and be able to find
work right
now during this pandemic,
apart from complying  The American dream in
the USA
is to learn the English language.
We all come from other countries, but
when we come to the USA
we have to learn English in
order to improve ourselves if we want to fulfill
our dreams, open a business or
become a manager or supervisor in
our jobs.
sometimes all that requires learning
English so we here at the
immigrant's house understand the im  importance
of learning in English and
we also understand that right now during
kobe 19 and this pandemic many people
cannot pay for these courses so you
can open more reasons we are
offering these free classes in
collaboration with the college of southern
nevada and green day nevada  to be able to
help people get through
these difficult times
exactly so apart from
ESL classes we are also offering free classes
for reading cosa for people who
couldn't graduate from high school and
want to come back to get their  diploma and
we are also going to be offering these
types of courses now there are many jobs
that are available right now but that
require at least having the xii so
these are also classes courses that
we are going to be offering free and the
two English courses as they are from
language and also those from yiyi
can also open other doors to start
other careers in the  college of southern
nevada or if so this can
open many doors not only for work
but also opportunities to study
other careers at the college of southern
nevada
for all people who are
interested in these courses can
call the and olivia  that the
telephone number is 70 26 51 44 87
normally you can call luz y oliva
who represents the school of your renovation
and you can call 70 26 51 44 87